- [Mark] The last time we
did one of my favorite videos
on my channel, which, where
we talked about helping
- Yeah
- [Mark] people.
And I think some things have
happened since that talk
which is only a month or two ago
that I think we can add to it.
So, so this will be
like a part two of that.
- Yeah, sure.
Let's do it.
- [Mark] So we touched on
this a little bit there,
but I've I've learned
since, since we spoke last,
how,
how can, how
what's the word it's
just, it's such a, but you
you watch my videos and
you're like, Oh my God,
I wanna help this person
or, or, or comment,
or you'll say Mark, you
didn't help this person.
And they don't understand how incredibly
difficult it is to get
these people to accept help.
Cause even though they
might say, I just need help.
- Yeah
- [Mark] And they're, they're crying.
And everything is like, you know, seems
like all they need is to walk
into rehab and everything will be cool.
But what I've learned is
there are so many obstacles
that are in the way of all that
because what I've seen
is the ability to make
a good choice a wise decision
is almost like impossible for these people
who were molested or abused as children.
When you were
when you were
sexually abused or physically abused
or verbally abused when
you were six years old,
it almost it seems to me like, it, it,
it crosses the wires in your brain.
So what's good is now useless.
You avoid it and what's
bad becomes attractive
and that's all you'll seek.
And it seems that that's
all that we'll respond to
is something that is a bad decision.
Everyone would, would say it
it'd be unanimous that, Oh, no
that's a bad, that's the wrong decision
- Right
- [Mark] but that's what they go for.
- Yeah. Well, what I find
fascinating is the parallel
between when we talk about getting people
off the street or getting people out
of what we deem to be a horrendous
situation, because it is
there's so much parallel between that
and those of us that aren't on the street
and are more privileged, but keep going
for the same shitty guy
that treats us like shit
or keep, we stay at the
same job that we hate
because we're afraid to
go for another job where
we may not be, you know, as comfortable.
We all have as humans
a fear of a certain level
of success, or, or whatever
it may be succeeding in general
not necessarily monetary success
but just succeeding in general.
We all have a fear of it.
It's just that these people have it
on a level that
is so deep
and so painful that they
mistreat their bodies and they
they mistreat each other
and it just it's dark.
And it's at the very, very bottom.
But I think,
again, we talk about
the fact that I want to
we all want to humanize what's happening.
This happens to all of us at a level.
It's just that this level looks
and is on paper worse, obviously.
Cause they're not as functional
as members of society
but we all have that instinct to run
and self-sabotage, it's just
some are more socially acceptable.
- [Mark] Yeah. I mean,
people may be like you and me
and a lot of my audience
might have a little bit
of that self-sabotage going
on in their relationships
and in your career, in your
personality and whatever.
And that's maybe why
that my channels kind of
become somewhat popular is
we can all relate to these stories.
They're extreme versions of
ours stories, but this is what
this is what our self
destructive tendencies
on steroids looks like.
- Yeah, this is what it looks
like when out of the gate,
somebody is like, you ain't shit.
You're not worth it.
They mistreat you.
They teach you when
you're still in your zero
to eight years of really
absorbing everything around you.
They teach you then you're worthless.
Of course you carry that
into the rest of your life.
Anybody would, if you
had different resources
perhaps it would look different.
I do have friends who have
been through molestation
who aren't on the street
but this is how it ends up sometimes.
And other times you're
functional and you pay your rent
but you still have that same tendency when
the doors are closed
and everything's quiet.
- [Mark] Yeah, you and I
speak on the phone sometimes
and we were having a conversation
about somebody I was trying to help
and I was very frustrated
with, and, and I asked you
at some point, like, are
these people even helpable?
Is it even possible to
change them, to fix them?
Because I, you know, at
some point on my channel
I've interviewed almost 2,500 people
only a Norman and Eric
are the only two people
I can say that are really
making a serious effort
doing the right thing.
And hopefully they're gonna make it out.
But everybody else just can't
or won't or whatever word you wanna use.
And I asked you, like,
do people ever change?
And, and your answer was
interesting where you said
you tell me what you said.
You said that, that we just
incrementally will change.
We won't, we won't.
- Yeah. So we look at we when
people watch your channel
or are involved in what I
do, they sort of think that
if you throw all these resources
at a person that overnight
they're just gonna be
this different person.
And if you think about people
who are functioning members
of society we don't even work that way.
We don't wake up one day
and completely alter the
way that we live our lives
and our surroundings.
The same thing can be said
about these people as humans
we are just making incremental
efforts to be better
but change and fix don't
they're not applicable
in a broad term.
I mean, sure.
There are those people
that hit rock bottom
and they go fuck, I need
to do something different.
But for the most part, we're
all just taking baby steps
toward what we deem to be the
right way to live our lives.
And for these people, there
are so many steps just
to become base level safe
and functional that it's like
we can't expect to throw something
at them and for them to
just go, Oh, well, great
my life is fixed
but we have a tendency to
assume that that's the case
and we do that in all aspects of humanity.
We tend to do that.
We like to just throw something
and go, well, it's fixed.
What's your problem?
- [Mark] Yeah, well, I, I
think it's human nature.
I'm very guilty of it where
you just want to oversimplify
and be like,
Oh you just need to go to
rehab and you'll be fine.
Well, rehab would be part of it.
But then the ability to not self-sabotage
until you die, would be helpful.
And to be able to make good decisions
and to be able to handle
money and not just burn it
as soon as you have it in your
hands, in order to, you know
the ability to build trust
the, in order to, you know
trust others, the ability to
do so many things that you
and I take for granted
that these people are
just totally incapable of.
- Right, yeah
- [Mark] How will your, how
will you ever teach them that?
They need a new childhood
as we talked before.
- Right? And that's where
mental health comes in.
And I think now we're having
those conversations more
than we had previously.
- [Mark] It's all about mental health
- But, that's such a large hurdle.
And it's the people who are living
on the streets are the last
people that are going to
get access to whatever this new focus
on mental health even brings about.
Because first it goes to those
of us that can pay for it.
And that still make all
of these corporations
the money they need to make.
And then very last come the
people that, that need it in a
in a very dire way, in some cases.
So yeah, I can throw money
at Christina or whoever
or I can say, let's go
to rehab right now today.
I can pick her up in my car
but self-sabotage is the nature of trauma.
And so she's gonna go
back to what she knows
because we're not gonna be
able to there's no, it's
it's 30, 40 years of of
therapy to get somebody
truly you know in most cases, anyway,
I can't speak for everybody.
I'm not a therapist but it's so
it's so deep that it's
like, we can't just expect
for there to just throw
a tape on a fucking
on something that's broken and go, well
why aren't you, why isn't it working now?
I don't get it.
- [Mark] Yeah, there,
there are so many people
that viewers would love
to see followups on
that I've interviewed or
that we've tried to help
that I just can't bring them in again
because it's just too humiliating.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] If you knew the backstory of what
what they actually did
when they were offered help
on a silver platter, everything
they would ever need, rehab
education, job, training
therapy, you name it, everything.
And they, what they did with
that, which is, you know
either the help either turns
into enabling, or it turns
or they flake very often they flake
or they just get angry it at
you because you're, you're
you're representing something
that they just aren't capable
of doing.
- Right.
- [Mark] Incapable and they
get angry because you're
you're trying to do something
that they just can't
and they resent.
It just gets ugly and
- Yes.
- [Mark] And I can't do
those videos cause it's just
what these people are not just,
I can't just humiliate them like that.
- Well a lot of times,
if you have been fervent
in your efforts to try and help them
they don't even wanna come in
because they don't wanna face
you and, and say, yeah, no
I turned down the help
because they know deep
down in there somewhere
that that is valuable
help that we're offering, but
it is humiliating for them.
And it,
like I said, like I keep saying, it just
it runs so deep, but yeah,
there's a level of humiliation.
And that's why I talk
about the fact that we
in this country specifically,
cause this is where I live.
And this is the country I know most about.
We have to figure out how to
have a sense of community.
Because if these people, if people
in general experienced
more kindness day to day
our efforts wouldn't be so futile,
but it's because all day, every day,
they're for the most part
not experiencing humanity
and kindness that us showing
up out of nowhere just
seems fucking crazy.
It does.
And I get that, like, it's like, you know
with anything else
if you date horrible people all the time
and then a nice person comes
along nine times out of 10
you ain't even want anything
to do with that person.
- [Mark] You don't trust them.
- No, you're like, what's wrong with you?
Why are you being so nice to me?
Why are you treating me so
well, it's the same concept.
It's just different setting.
- [Mark] Yeah, being human is tough, man.
- It's a challenge.
And I think the only way out of this is to
to truly start to care for each other
no matter what we look
like, no matter what we have
in our bank account, it is about a sense
of community and a sense of
responsibility to each other.
And right now, culturally, in this country
we don't have that.
We can't wait to point the finger
and blame and separate and
divide and it's gonna ruin us.
- [Mark] Yeah
No, I, I see all the hate
in some, some certain videos
like today I posted a pimp
video and it's just got tons
of haters and the sex
offenders, same thing.
So I turned off those comments, but
but all that hate accomplishes nothing.
Do you think he's gonna say, Oh wow.
People don't like what I'm doing.
I'm gonna stop doing this.
He's he's not, he
it just makes him feel
more shame, more guilt.
And that makes him behave
badly for another 20 years.
- Right.
- [Mark] It just, it just shame
and guilt and, and you know
all the negativity he gets
doesn't change anything.
The only way is to understand,
forgive, accept, help
you know, by learning and
and forgiving.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Only change, only
then is change possible.
But I'm not saying we're
gonna transform a pimp
who is hardcore, you know, beating and,
and exploiting women.
And he's gonna, he's gonna
become a humanitarian.
I don't think that.
- No, yeah, exactly.
But, but we can show kindness.
- [Mark] What's that?
- We can show, we can exercise
kindness and understanding.
And I'm not saying we need
to go shake his hand and say
thank you for exploiting women.
But what we can do is
is offer humanity to the women that are
under him and even offer a
level of humanity to him.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And maybe a little communication, maybe
maybe explaining how, how
humans should treat each other
and maybe he'll grow a little bit.
I'm not saying anyone's
going to be transformed but
- No but it's worth a try.
Hating him and marginalizing
him and beating him
over the head about what he's chosen to do
definitely isn't doing anything
- [Mark] No, it accomplishes,
it actually puts fertilizer on
on what he's already doing.
- Right.
- [Mark] He'll do, he'll do it more.
- Well it's like me.
I got a, I think I told you that
after the last video I got
a letter sent to my office
to me is really amazing.
I got a letter sent to my office
about the content of
what I was talking about
and it was totally focused on race.
And I don't think I even brought
up, I I'm almost positive.
I didn't bring up race in
our interview because that
wasn't what I was referring to.
- [Mark] No we've never even
- But it was a letter
that basically was saying
that white people are victims
and how dare I spread
liberal Marxist rhetoric
and whatever else kind of summing it up.
That's what it said.
That letter only makes
me more motivated to
continue to do what we're doing now.
Because I,
the negativity that people think
if they shame you
that you're gonna do something different.
No, you have, you have fired me up.
And now I'm excited to go deeper
into the things that matter to me.
- [Mark] Yeah. Shame, shame adds
to whatever behavior
you're, you're shaming
- Right? So in my case,
it's like socially acceptable behavior
cause I'm doing my best to
spread the knowledge I do have
- [Mark] No, but if you were,
if you were selling drugs
and somebody said, you
gotta stop doing that.
That's terrible.
You're, you're a evil bitch
You wouldn't stop doing it.
You would, you would do it.
You would do it for another 15 years.
- We have tried being ugly to each other
and it's not working.
- [Mark] Doesn't work.
- So it's worth it to commit
to trying something else.
That's all that I'm saying.
Like, I don't have all the
answers, but being nasty
it's not working out very well.
So how about, we just don't.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] I love that.
- Keep it to yourself.
Because whatever you have
inside that makes you want to
be that way to another human
being says more about you
and your trauma and your experiences.
than it could ever say
about me, and I'm sorry
to whoever hurt you in such a
way that you feel the need to
go after the people on the
street or me or Mark or whatever.
But I'm, I'm understanding
enough of the human condition
as are you to know that that's
just a reflection of them
- [Mark] Something,
something they went through
- Yes
- [Mark] Or something that
something they're feeling.
- Yes.
And if we can all really try
to adapt that principle of like
whatever's going on over
here is strictly over here.
And isn't a reflection of us.
Perhaps we can get to
a place where the hate
and all of that just becomes
uncool to even bother doing
because the people you're sending it
to it bounces right off
and then there's more kindness.
And then we take care of each other
and then perhaps there's
a little bit less struggle
and pain in the world, perhaps.
- [Mark] Wouldn't that be awesome.
That would be great.
That's what we're all trying to do here.
- [Mark] All right, Monica.
Thank you so much for
another informative talk.
- [Monica] Thank you.
- [Mark] You're always interesting.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
- [Monica] What time is
Julian gonna be here?